this month marks 40 years since the
birth of the first baby conceived
through in-vitro fertilization
Louise joy Braun more than 8 million
babies have been born using that
technique advances in IVF testing
improve outcomes for couples with
infertility but these advances are also
stirring debate over so called mosaic
embryos those are embryos with both
normal and abnormal cells they could not
be detective but detected before the
improved genetic screenings
dr. tara Narula shows us why some
fertility experts are torn about whether
mosaic embryos should be implanted tara
good morning good morning Alex while
some doctors are hesitant to implant an
embryo that tests with some abnormal
cells for patients struggling with
fertility and with limited options
mosaic embryos may offer new hope for
one couple we spoke to these embryos
were their last chance at a dream of
having a family and gave them reason to
live after suffering the unimaginable in
2015 Mary Jo and Shane done lost their
only child Luke to a rare cancer at 17
months old I just didn't imagine
continuing to live without my baby it
was just excruciating pain I was
determined that this wasn't going to be
the thing that was going to ruin us the
Dunn's decided to try for another child
but in their mid-forties new conceiving
would be hard they endured nearly two
years of failed in vitro fertilization
treatments after six egg retrievals and
$70,000 their hopes of a child came down
to two remaining embryos embryos the
Dunn's initially set aside the reason
they didn't test genetically normal you
skip them scientifically they weren't
perfect right and then the end result is
those are the two that were perfect twin
girls Riley and Kelsey were born nine
months later the embryo testing the
Dunn's opted for is called PGs testing
pre-implantation genetic screening it
takes a biopsy of just a handful of
cells from the outer layer of an embryo
to determine if it's chromosomal ehealth
then classified as normal or abnormal in
2014 advances in this screening made it
possible to detect when an embryo has a
mix of normal and abnormal cells called
mosaic embryos the twins grew from
mosaic embryos doctors believe in some
cases those abnormal cells can self
correct or be pushed to the placenta
leaving the embryo healthy but because
the biopsy is small the challenge is
knowing the extent of abnormality and
what that means for pregnancy how did
they explain what mosaic means the
mosaic embryo can either fail to implant
and you could miscarry you could have a
child with birth defects or you could
have a perfectly healthy baby that's
with every pregnancy right really but
the decision to transfer these embryos
using IVF is spurring debate among
fertility experts dr. Jamie Grifo is the
director of NYU Langone fertility center
mosaic embryos are not abnormal embryos
abnormal embryos don't make babies or
pregnancies mosaic embryos have
potential they don't have the same
potential as a chromosomal a normal
embryo but they can make babies though
Griffo says mosaic embryos carry a
higher risk of miscarriage we have to
learn which ones are more likely to make
the baby and which ones are less likely
and then patients get to decide whether
you use that embryo according to one
study mosaic embryos create a baby
roughly one-third of the time out of 78
transferred mosaic embryos the study
found 24 healthy babies were born but
some doctors like Mandy Katz Jaffe
scientific director at the Colorado
Center for Reproductive Medicine caution
against implanting mosaic embryos
pointing to a lack of long-term studies
of babies born from them we really don't
know the answer to the full question of
what is the probability that a mosaic
embryo will result in either affected
baby or a healthy baby for the Dunn's
they believe they are living proof of
its value if one person sees this
interview
and decides you know what I have a
mosaic embryo that I was questioning
whether or not to transfer here we are
like it's worth taking that chance the
lab the test of the Dunn's embryos
Cooper genomics is seeing a growing
trend in fertility doctors requesting
mosaic reporting but many of the roughly
400 clinics nationwide still only report
normal or abnormal results a committee
of the American Society for Reproductive
Medicine found earlier this year that
they didn't have enough information to
form an opinion on what percentage of
normal cells is needed to be recommended
for use I am sure this is something
furious debate a lot of community I have
been for me had never heard of the
mosaic embryos before but it's
interesting to hear that some of these
abnormal cells which are present that
can then self-correct the body can self
correct those absolutely and you just
hear their story and it couldn't have
happened this miracle to a better family
for them it was a risk worth taking it
was it brought them home on Christmas
Day
oh really oh it's an incredible story
we're very happy for them Thank You Tara